vva il faut parler franchement
aujourd'hui le gros problème de loana je
me permets au lycée elle a dit cissé la
nacam c'est la came c'est la drogue liés
aux jantes on nous a dit qu'elle avait
repris de la drogue apparemment et c'est
pour ça qu'elle est retombé et l'aurait
privé du gsb d'accord donc péril vous
lorsque vous étiez avec elle j'ai eu un
texto de loana aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui
vous a dit manat si c'est ton ami neil
one moi c'est ma petite soeur tu vois
moi c'est ma petite sur l'aude et on a
eu très fort pour le web très très peur
j'ai appelé c'est moi même qui ai appelé
le sait même temps sur l'eau on a vu
cela par les caves et dans les médias
qu'ils a montré qu'elle était entre la
vie et la mort moi ça fait deux jours
qu'on ne dort pas tu comprends oui la
loi n'a m'a envoyé encore désolé pour
hier sylvie m'a donné un peu trop de
médicaments parce que j'étais stressé et
du coup j'ai mal supporté non ça là je
lui ai donné la veille à nax oui je le
sais j'ai le même message
ou alors un axe ses attentions alwan le
très fragile on l'a calmé parce que là
mois à l'hôpital c'est moi qui devais
emmener je suis rentré avec sa valise
est en fait dans son sang c'est bien du
siège hbh belga mais qui eût elle
dansera kg qui lui a donné ça de toute
façon si tu es quelque chose qu'on ne
peut pas détecter à l'aéroport doute
qu'il eut deux aspects
elle peut le commander sur internet est
partout sur internet où le discernement
pour faire ça en ce moment de commander
soeur je ne porterai pas le chapeau qui
n'aura pas le chapeau déjà jeudi dès
aujourd'hui faut juste pour recadrer
entier alors je ne fais pas ton procès
voilà je vais faire je vais revenir sans
je tiens il me plaît tu sais quoi je
sais dire que c'est
vous êtes tous entrain de pleurer loana
mais qui va la voir qui va lui apporter
des mouchoirs c'est très bien alors je
vais revenir justement je suis avec vous
tous j'aimerais pas